so
what i want to talk about next is a
solution uh
to to these questions any part in
particular the method we'll talk about
is called query to box
that allows us to reason our knowledge
graphs using
what is called box embeddings so let me
first
motivate the setting and then give you
how this method works
so we said we want to answer more
complex
predictive queries on graphs and let's
say that we want to be able to also
include
conjunction so not just paths but also
intersections we want to be able to take
an intersection of two sets
in the embedding space what we need to
be able to do is two things
we need to be able to now figure out how
are we going to represent
a set of entities in the embedding space
and then how are we going to define the
intersection operator
in the embedding space right how do we
quickly take uh
two sets of entities and say what are
the entities that are in the
intersection
between them so let's see how to do that
the key inside that will allow us to do
this
is the concept of a box embedding so
what this means is that
we are going to embed uh all the
entities
and the relations in our uh
space as boxes as multi-dimension
dimensional rectangles and the intuition
will be that every box
is defined by two points right it's
defined by the center
and is defined by the corner we'll call
the center center
and we'll call the corner offset so this
basically tells me
you know what is the offset in uh one
dimension what is the offset in the
other dimension this basically tells me
what is the size of the box and
intuitively we want
to uh let's say in our case of a full
restaurant
we want to embed all of its side effects
in a in a box uh that is um
so that in basically uh all the side
effects caused by full restaurant will
be
will be embedded close together and they
will be enclosed
in this uh in this box so that's the
that's the idea so let me now tell you
uh keep
kind of building on this so um the
reason why we want to embed
things as boxes is because intersection
of boxes
is well defined right basically what i
mean by that is
if you take two boxes and take an
intersection intersection of two boxes
is a box it can be an empty box right
side
box of size zero but if there is any
non-trivial
overlap that overlap will be a box so it
means
we can now think about how are we going
to define
trans geometric transformations over
these boxes
that corresponds to logical operators
right so when we traverse the knowledge
graph to find answers
each step will basically produce a set
of reachable entities
a set of entities that the query covers
so far
and we are going to now model this set
of entities
with a box that encloses all of them
right so
um this means that we can that box
provide a powerful obstruction because
boxes kind of enclose uh sets of
entities and then we can define
geometric intersection operator
over let's say two or multiple boxes
and we when we intersect them the
intersection is still a box
so we it's very easy again to have this
compositional property
where we can take boxes intersect them
in arbitrary ways
but we always are left left out with a
box
which we can further kind of manipulate
and change and shape however we like
so that's why this is kind of cool um
and uh
exciting so what does it mean
to be a to be able to embed with boxes
here is what we need to figure out or
here is what we need to learn
we need to learn uh we need to learn
entity embeddings
so every embedded entity will have an
embedding and it will be a box but it
will be a
trivial box so basically it will be a
point right it will be
a box of uh size zero or volume zero
then we'll have relation embeddings
which will basically
generalize the notion of transient where
we are going to take
now learn how to move around and
expand or shrink boxes so the relation
embeddings will be like
vectors that are going to take boxes
and move them around and then
intersection operator
is something that is that is new uh the
intersection operator will take a
multiple boxes on the input
and will output a single box and
intuitively this will be an
intersection of uh boxes but we are
going to
learn this uh intersection operator um
so it will have some parameters so that
our uh approach will be even
more uh expressive and more robust
so how will this work let me just kind
of give you a cartoon
again we are talking about uh you know
what are drugs that cause
shortness of breath and treat the
diseases associated with protein
esr ii um the way we do this right in
terms of query plan we say
we start with a anchor entity esr2 we
want to move across the
across the relationship called
associated
with and the way we are going to do this
is that we are going to define this
relation projection operator p uh here
is how it's defined we'll have
one for every relation and essentially
what this will do is it will take one
box
and it will kind of move it according to
a given relation
and also um expand its uh or shrink its
size so basically
we will have um this learned
uh this learned uh operator for every
relation
it's going to move the center and it's
going to change
the offset so basically it will change
the size as well as the location
of the box so i can start with q
and then i apply this projection r to it
to get a new box q prime so that's the
projection operator
so how would this look in our case if i
started dsr2 and i want to move across
the
associated relation i would take this
trivial box apply my
uh uh are associated and basically this
would move it
uh and expand it to include uh all the
all the diseases associated with esr
ii now um now that i have a new box i
can again simply kind of follow the
query plan
now i want to traverse over a treated by
which again i would take this box apply
treated by
the projection operator the
transformation to the box
which would you know further move it and
you know expand or shrink it depends
what the model we learn
and then the idea is that whatever are
the answers to this
path to uh predictive query those are
the entities uh
inside uh the box and that's essentially
the idea
right now i can also try to answer the
second part of the query which is
shortness of breath caused by so i start
with the shortness of breath entity
apply this
caused by box transformation to get
another box
and now what are the entities that are
in the intersection of the two boxes uh
those will be basically the answers to
my query in our
uh in our case uh this would be this uh
these two entities
uh full restaurant uh in the other drug
right so that's
essentially the idea i have one box i
have the other box i'm interested in
what is the intersection of them
so that's um the idea about how would i
do the embedding with boxes now let me
talk about
how does how is this intersection
operator uh
really defined uh one approach would be
to simply define it as kind of hardcore
or just mathematically as intersection
of boxes almost like as
as in a venn diagram we want to be a bit
more
flexible and we want to do
and learn a geometric intersection
operator we'll call it j
where the idea is we want to take
multiple boxes as input and produce the
intersection
of these boxes we'll call it the
intersection box
and the intuition we are going to use is
to say the center of the new box
should be close to the centers of the
input boxes right these are the
three input boxes and their centers um
so we would like to take kind of
intuitively the intersection between
them
so we want the new center to be kind of
a function
of these three centers and we want the
intersection to be kind of close
to them and then the offset so the size
of the box
should shrink since uh the size of the
intersection
is smaller than the size of any
of the input sets or any of the input
boxes so
formally we'll have this intersection
operator that will take
an arbitrary set of boxes and produce a
new box
now the way we define this operator is
we need to say
what is happening to the center and what
is happening to the offset
of the intersection the way we are going
to find the center
of the intersection is we are going to
do this through a learned opera
operation and our learned operation will
take the following it will take the
centers of the boxes that are on the
input
and then we are going to uh learn this
function f
that takes a center of the box and
um and transforms it
and then we will apply soft max to this
to this function and what this will
allow us to do uh
is that basically the the intuition is
that the center
of the intersection will be somewhere in
this green region defined by the centers
of the input boxes
and we define the center as a weighted
sum of the input box centers where w
is this uh weight the importance of uh
of a given box on the intersection of
boxes
so w represents in some sense a
self-attention score
on the cen how much a center of each
input box affects
the center of the intersection box uh
and this
funny operator is called hadamard
product which is basically element wise
product right it's just
you you uh take product of cells
uh that correspond uh to each other
so this is how center uh of the
is defined and of course f is a function
that we are going to learn
uh similarly now we also have to define
the offset
and the way we are going to define the
offset of the intersection
is to take is we'll take the mean the
smallest of all the input boxes so we
take the minimum
in terms of the offsets um and then we
are going to
also learn this uh offset function f
offset that is going to aggregate and
transform the offsets
so here the the intuition is that we
first take the minimum
of the offsets of input boxes and then
make the model more expressive by
introducing
introducing this new function f off
for extracting the representation of the
input boxes
with a sigmoid function to guarantee
shrinking of the of the offset
and again this f off will have some
trainable parameters
uh that will uh that we are going to
learn through the training process
of the entire model so uh
you know intuitively the idea is that
once i have two boxes on the input
i wanna i wanna produce the intersection
of the two boxes
and in our case the intersection of the
two boxes for example would be this uh
shaded uh area here and that
and whatever entities are enclosed or
are close to this box
uh those are the answers uh to our query
so now what we need to do is so far i
said
oh um entities that are the answer that
are included
in the box they have to be kind of
inside the box
right in reality this might be uh harder
because
data is noisy there might be
inconsistencies contradictions in the
knowledge graph
so we need to define the notion of
distance
between the box and a point and the idea
will be that
we are going to define this distance to
have two parts
we are going to define the distance from
the center to the point
if the point is inside the box and if
it's outside the box then we'll take the
distance between the center and the
corner and the corner
and the point um and the point here is
that we want to be able to
uh account for the distance differently
right we want to measure
a distance uh uh from the center
if when the when the point is inside the
box in some set of units
and then we are going to have this uh
weight scalar
alpha that will uh uh be less than one
so that basically
we we are going to penalize the the the
distance
from the center of the box uh more if
the point is
uh inside than if it is uh outside the
box uh and the intuition is that if the
point isn't closing the box
it should the box should be it should be
very close uh to the center of the box
so that we get
more uh robustness from our from our
approach right we don't want a point
to be kind of close to the border or the
edge of the box
we want it towards uh the center of the
box
so that's how we now define the distance
between the entity and the box
so now when we have the final embedding
of the query
all we do is basically apply this
distance
and say who are the points that are
closest according to this distance
uh to the center of the box
so now we have discussed two things we
discussed
how we can embed everything uh all the
entities as boxes
how we learn the the box transformation
operation
the projection operation that is one per
relation and then we talked about how we
learn this
intersection uh conjunction operator
that takes the as an input a set of
boxes
and produces the intersection box
of course a natural question next is
could i
could i have this predictive queries
even with a union operator so for
example to be able to answer queries
like
or and so next what we are going to look
at is
how would you be able to answer what we
will call end or queries or
what is um technically called
existential positive
first order queries so basically these
are queries with
conjunction and disjunction operator
right so the question is how would we be
able to this are we able to design
a disjunction operator and embed
and or queries in low dimensional vector
space and be able to
answer predictive and on and or
queries in the space as well
so the question is can we embed an end
or queries in a low dimensional space
the answer is actually no uh the reason
for that is that
allowing union over arbitrary
sets requires high dimensional
embeddings
so let me quickly give you a sense why
we need a lot of
dimensions imagine i'm given three
queries q1 q2 q3
and each one of them has one answer uh
you know q1 has v1 as an
entity vivana's answer q2v2 and q2q3
v3 entity as the answer so now imagine i
i allow an entity operation right which
basically means
i can take any pair of queries and do an
or between them so the answer set will
be uh the
the answer set for the first query union
the answer set
uh of the second query so given that we
have
two queries uh sorry given that we have
three queries
the question is uh can would be able to
model union operation
when we embed them let's say on a
two-dimensional plane
um and yes you could right basically you
say
for every individual query i can simply
put a box
around the entity and this would mean
for a given query
i want the entity that is the answer to
it to be inside the box
and that's you know easy to achieve
right we can
space this entities apart and put a box
around each one of them and say aha
the box is the embedding of the query
and the answer to the query is embedded
inside the box you know all good how
about
the unions um
in this case i can easily do the union
right this is for example
how a box of union one query one union
query two
would look like so q1 or q2
this is how q2 or q3 would look like and
this is how
q1 or q3 would look like so it seems
all all works for three queries in two
dimensions
however um uh what if we have
four points so imagine now i have four
queries i have
four queries each one with one entity as
the answer
can i now use a two-dimensional space to
embed
them um and be able to do arbitrary
unions between arbitrary queries
um and it turns out i cannot design a
box embedding
such that for example in this case uh
you that would represent the union of q
q2 or q4 because
there will always be some other kind of
box or some other entity
um uh in in between them right and if i
move this
entity away perhaps here then i won't be
able to to
to model the union between v1 and v4
so basically um there will always be
some issue and what is the conclusion or
if you
if you do the mathematics carefully
what turns out is that if you have uh
m queries or m entities
um with non-overlapping answers um
then you need the dimensionality of
order m
to handle arbitrary or queries right so
in our case we said if i have three
queries i need two dimensions
if i have four queries i need three
dimensions and so on and so forth
so because the real world uh knowledge
graph have
a lot of entities for example you know
3 base 15k has 15 000 entities and it's
considered a small knowledge graph
this would mean that if we want to be
able to to a model
arbitrary or operation between
arbitrary sets of entities uh this would
mean we need an embedding dimension of
fifteen thousand
and uh that's far uh far too much uh for
us to be able to do this
so um it seems um hopeless right since
we cannot embed
uh and or queries in low dimensional
space can we still handle them
and actually the answer is yes and the
answer is yes because
we can rewrite the query to um in
into a different forum so that the query
is kind of logically equivalent
but the union operation happens all at
the end
right so the idea is if i have the
original query plan where i you know
take two projections
take the union take one more projection
and take then take an intersection
i can rewrite this into a different
query plan that gives me
the identical answer it's logically
equivalent
but the union only happens at the end
so why is this beneficial because i
already know how to answer this part
to get a box i know how to answer this
this part up to here to get a box
so now uh what is the answer to my query
you simply
entities included in the first box and
entities included in the second box so
that's very
easy to do because the union uh occurs
uh always as as a last step
so what is important is any and or query
can be transformed into a
an equivalent what is called um
disjunctive normal form which is a
disjunction
of conjunctive queries um and this means
that if i have a query that's now
a disjunction of conjunctions i can
simply first answer these conjunctions
and then take the or or the union at the
end
so it means we can aggregate these
unions
at the last step there is one caveat
is that when you do this uh
transformation into disjunctive normal
form so from the original query to the
disjunctive normal form
the size of the query can increase
exponentially
um but in our case this is not the
problem because answering
queries um is so uh is so fast it's
just kind of uh navigating the embedding
space so this doesn't
um doesn't sound like a too big of a
problem
so now that we have um defined
the uh the disjunctive normal form and
we have rewritten
the uh the query as a set of conjunctive
queries and then
apply the or operation at the end then
all we need to do is to change the
notion of the distance
between the query uh the embedding of
the query um
and the entity and the way we can write
this out mathematically is very
intuitive
we say that the query in the disjunctive
normal form
conjunctive query q1 or q2 or q3
we can simply define the distance
between the embedding of this query
and the entity to be to be the minimum
of the distances
between the the box distances between
the individual conjunctive queries and
that entity so basically we say
the entity is an answer uh to the
query if it is inside at least
one of the individual conjunctive query
boxes right so that it is
closed to at least one of the
uh conjunctive queries q so that's why
we have the minimum here right
so as long as v is the answer to one
conjunction query q
then the distance between that query and
v will be
very small and we achieve this by using
this
minimum based distance
so this now uh uh
allows us basically to to answer uh
arbitrary and or
uh predictive queries so the way we
would go about this
if as we are given a query queue
at the beginning we would rewrite it
into a disjunctive normal form so a
disjunction of conjunctive queries q1 to
qm
we would embed this q1 to qm using this
set of box operations meaning
projections
and intersections and then we would
simply calculate the box distance
between
each qi from the disjunctive normal form
and anti-tv and take the minimum of this
distances and then the final score of an
entity
is simply this is this minimum base
distance between the entire
uh query uh and the and the embedding
of a given entity uh for which we are
interested in assessing
how likely is that entity an answer uh
to our
uh to our query so
now we have talked about how the method
works
uh from the point of view of once the
embeddings are there
once the box operators are there how do
we apply it to answer
an arbitrary predictive query the
question
is uh what kind of training procedure do
we use
to learn this all what does this mean is
we need basically a similar
setup similar to knowledge graph
completion task so that we can learn
all these parameters right when i say
parameters i mean we need to learn
entity embeddings
we need to learn these relation
embeddings these box transformations and
we need to learn
the intersection operator
and the way we are going to learn this
is basically that we are going to select
uh or sample or create a set of queries
for every query we are going to have a
positive set of entities this will be a
set of answers
we are going to have a negative set of
entities this will be
non-answers and our goal will be to
to learn all these parameters in such a
way
that answers are included in the final
box
and on answers are outside the box
so let me summarize this so
we are going to first randomly sample
query queue
from the training knowledge graph and
identify
an an entity tv that is the answer uh to
that query
then we are also going to identify some
negative entity
let's call it v prime that is not an
answer to the query
right so for example i could say uh i
start
with let's go back to our barack obama
nationality american
so i would say i would sample a query
um nationality this is a simple kind of
knowledge graph completion query not
even a multi
multi-hop uh i start with obama along
the nationality i find american so
that's a positive entity and then
perhaps i say
a negative entity could be some other
random entity in
uh in the graph um perhaps it could be
paris or if i want to be smarter i say i
had the true entities of type
american so united states so i want to
pick another country perhaps germany
as a negative example as a non-answer
to this query now that
i now that i have sampled the query and
the answer a non-answer
i embed the query using the
transformations
and then i calculate the score function
f
of entity v which is the answer entity
and the entity v prime
which is the non-answer uh entity
and then the goal is that now i can
compute the gradients
uh with respect uh to this uh loss
function
l where the goal is to maximize
the the score of the entity v so
basically
uh it means maximize the negative
distance which means minimize the
distance
while minimizing uh the distance
of the non-answer so the the way we
write the loss is we say
sigma is a sigmoid function uh that has
value you know between zero and one
so basically i'm saying i want uh to
maximize f for the answer
and i want to minimize f for the
non-answer and now i can take
gradient or derivative with respect to
this loss function
to then be able to update both the
entity embeddings
as well as the projection and
intersection operator parameters
in order to be able to learn this uh
well
of course we are not only to going to
sample
once one hop queries we are also going
to sample two hop queries three hop
queries
intersection type queries uh all kinds
of different
uh query structures and that will be uh
our
uh training set and then given this
queries given an answer entity
and non-answer entity we are going to
optimize this likelihood
meaning we are going to find parameters
of the model which is
embeddings of entities plus these
operators
so that all this uh will optimize
the loss function so how do we
uh how do we instantiate a query
in the knowledge graph we will assume we
are given a query template
and then we uh instantiate the query
will simply be to do the backward
walking
uh what i mean by that is we are
basically start from the initial
answer entity and then we are kind of
going to walk backwards
towards the anchor entities right so um
in our case for example we could say
let's take full restaurant as our answer
entity
so now we are going now that we have
kind of randomly picked this entity from
the
knowledge graph we are going to kind of
move backward
along the knowledge graph to then get
the the query plan the query structure
right so we are just at full restraint
then we um move we say we are we need to
take intersection
of two relations relation one and
relation two so let's pick
two relations from a full restaurant and
move backward
and then now that we are here we moved
across treated by
uh now we can again move one step
backward along the projection operator
for the second type of relation like uh
associated
and uh now this will now become my
anchor entity and now
uh i do the same thing for the second
relation
uh here caused by and find the second
anchor entity so now i have just sampled
a query
that goes from esr to and shortness of
breath through
associated treated by as well as from
a shortness of breath to caused by and
the intersection of them is the full
restrand so this is now
my sampling of the query and then what i
can do
is find some entity that is not answer
to this query
and use that as a non answer
right it is important when we do this
sampling to be careful
uh because the query queue must have
answers
uh on the kg um and
we will take one of the answers as
instantiated uh
answer for our positive example and um
we are then going to basically randomly
sample some negative
examples non-answers which are basically
other entities uh in the knowledge graph
but we have to be careful that we are
not uh by accident
sampling some other entity that's also
uh answer
uh to the query so that's
uh essentially the idea um and
the the impressive thing is that we can
actually make this
uh all work and that now we are able to
answer arbitrary
uh predictive queries in knowledge
graphs uh even though
they might be notoriously uh incomplete
or
uh may not have uh uh all the edges and
what i want to do to
finish the lecture is give you a quick
um
example of how would this look like so
for example here we are going to take
the free base 15 000 knowledge graph
which is a knowledge graph about real
world entities
people things like that and imagine we
want to have a query
uh you know who are all male
instrumentalists who play
string instruments right
and we are going to uh use our system
to learn the embedding of all the nodes
uh all the entities to learn the
projection operator
to learn the conjunction operator um and
then
we are going to take this uh high
dimensional embedding
and we are going to project it down to
just two dimensions
so we can visualize it right so um
here's the visualization right so here
is uh 15 000 different
dots one corresponding to the embedding
of
each entity and these are real entities
with real embeddings
and here is our query plan right we want
to answer
uh know who are male instrumentalists
who play string instruments
so we'll start with string instrument as
anchor entity
go over the
instance off relation to find all
instances of string instruments
then we are going to go over uh played
by
uh relation uh to identify all the all
the people
who play this string instruments any of
them right
and then we are going to go from node
mail to say
instant soft to find all the instances
of male
males in our data set and now we need to
take the intersection to find
all the males who are also playing any
of the string
instruments so let me show you how this
actually works in this
two-dimensional projection so uh the
anchor node for string instrument if you
would
uh locate it is actually here uh the
blue one
now i will take and apply a box
transformation
that will say what are the instances
of the string instrument right what are
all the individual string instruments
um and if i do this um actually notice
now
um the the the the dots will
have different types of colors true
positive means this is a string
instrument
inside the box um false negative means
this is a string instrument
outside the box uh false positive would
be
other entities that are not string
instruments but are inside the box
and true entities are non-string
instruments outside the box
and what you see here is that basically
we are able to perfectly
enclose all the string instruments
inside the box and there are
10 10 instances of a string instrument
in our data set
so we have just identified all the
string instruments in the embedding
space
now we want to take the box of um
all the string instruments and transform
it to cover
uh the the people uh females and males
right who play these instruments uh and
if we do this
uh here is the these are the entities
that are inside the box again because
this is a two-dimensional projection
you know this is not a box uh but in
high dimension cities
and again we see that we are able to
cover basically
um 98 percent of all the
all the uh all the all the
instrumentalists
of string instruments and that we have a
few false positives basically a few
other entities um that are not
of string instruments but are still
inside the box right so there is a bit
of error
but the point is now we have 472
instrumentalists both
musicians female and male who play
string instruments like a guitar
right so now uh with this let's move to
the second part
where we take the mail the node mail
um the ma the node uh is here uh and now
we wanna say
uh do the box transformation instance
off to cover
all the males in this knowledge graph
and if you do this
this is kind of the entities that are
inside
the mailbox it's 3500 of them so we
basically went from one entity to a
giant box
that covers uh 3 500 males
that are represented in this data set
now that we have these two boxes we want
to apply
the intersection operator to this
that you take the two boxes and take the
intersection between them
um and if you do this the intersection
um
has uh almost 400 different entities
and these are the entities that are
predicted
to be male players of string
uh instruments what is interesting
you see that basically we are able to
almost perfectly
answer uh this query even though we were
doing all these operations
directly in the embedding space and this
is just one example how we can basically
answer
arbitrary predictive queries over these
types of incomplete knowledge graphs
so um to summarize today's lecture
uh we introduced uh uh the problem of uh
logical reasoning in knowledge graphs
using embeddings
and in particular we talked about how
are we
formulating answering queries
as a predictive machine learning task so
we basically rather than
traversing the knowledge graph we have
defined the task
in terms of a binary prediction task
that says
predict what entities are the answer to
a given query
and the benefit of our approach is that
it is
very scalable meaning answering queries
is very simple because it just
requires transforming boxes and then
checking
what entities are inside the box
and it is also very robust because we
don't rely
on individual links of the knowledge
graph but we really rely
on the embeddings and the relationships
in the embedding space
and the key idea for today's lecture
was we want to embed queries by
navigating the embedding space right we
have this com
we took advantage of this compositional
property
of transient method and then we extended
transie
to this notion of box embeddings so that
we can then
define the intersection of boxes
and we learned how to transform boxes
according to given relations we call
this a projection operator
and then we also showed how the how the
union operations can also be carried out
carried out by rewriting the query into
a disjunctive normal form
and apply the union operator
all the way at the end
you